sur mes particulièrement parce qu'il
rongeait son frein parce qu'on lui avait
dit justement ne pas être le président
des petites blagues ce qu'on disait que
c'était pas un présidentiable ou un
président ne faisait pas de petites
blagues et lui qu'un homme qui est
plutôt tendance humour à pendant les
sympathiques au demeurant copé vous déjà
relié à une fonction le nom je n'ai pas
rencontré accueillir à l'employé caf un
dîner chez moi je à plusieurs fois oui
mais vous avez fait plusieurs dîners
avec françois hollande
bah oui quand même beaucoup parce que
julie et makoun très très bons amis donc
du coup ils sont venus à la maison et je
suis allé chez or quoi vous êtes allé
chez les hollande aussi haut et fort un
pot-au-feu délicieux non pour les feux
avec des cornichons coupé en la majeur
c'est vrai il a il a défoncé le
pot-au-feu lui non courants chez sa
grand-mère au poteau ses chocolats
quoique savais rien et mousse au
chocolat la norme et ben non j'ai pas
rapporté quand j'avais 7 chez moi ils
avaient a beaucoup apprécié l'homme
avait pris sur fois oui alors non mais
pour les téléspecteurs j'aime bien moi
ça parce que moi j'ai jamais eu
payot à dîner chez moi jamais eu
quelqu'un comme ça ses meilleurs chefs
d'état chez vrai leur chef d'état il
unit un chef nine et a retenu que j'ai
même pas eu rien à dire jusqu'à moi
j'habitais mais même moi je dîne pas
alors et est ce qu'est ce qu'on se dit
c'est qu'on raconte quoi vu le pib sur
la chine
oui oui qui croît avec un ancien
président alors mais déjà on est on est
un peu tendue parce qu'on veut pas alors
c'est moi j'étais un peu tendu parce que
je les parades raté le dîner j'avais
l'ambition j'avais une énorme pression
agnel donc mon compagnon et moi on
s'était mis une énorme pression au
niveau de revenus
ah ouais voulait pas rater les pattes
non on avait cherché quel pâte qu'elle
accompagne manqué c'est à dire c'est
tout ça en françois hollande il a
commencé à prendre la pâte comme à ckoi
la nourriture est là quand il a mangé la
pâte ils ont tous regardé elle a fait
comme as j'ai bon non mais le pire c'est
que comme le car les personnes voulaient
commencer et donc les pattes refroidisse
et non
et donc c'est très très mauvais signe
parce qu'on va te dire que les pâtes
continua clients dans l'assiette et donc
on était complètement désespéré on est
en transe piste est horrible c'est là
qu'ils ont des problèmes de fin de mois
quand j'invite de tabarre là la vérité
on s'en fout moorea c'est comme ça sans
poudre mais qui a déjà eu des des gens
importants chez de voilà très très
important chez qui c'est qui la personne
la plus importante que vous ayez invité
chez vous à la badini vous philippe
ouimet me fasse et il était mon ami
avant d'être ministre eric
dupond-moretti cdt déjà quelqu'un
d'important maintenant c'est une garde
des sceaux mais sait on parle de tout
sauf de choses importantes
je crois qu'ils parlent que truc
important toute la journée quand ils
achètent ses copains il ya bien sûr les
autres choses bernard montiel soir les a
laissés le patro que c'est le patron du
point soleil de ces politiques voulaient
dire alors politique nicolas sarkozy
il a mangé chez vous oui quoi il est
venu mon chien très rigolo parce que
c'était un couscous ce moment là il
était un peu triste parce que c'était le
départ de cécilia est en fait qu aux
sources avec yamina benguigui vous savez
larguant réalisatrice et il se trouve
que surtout l'idée c'est qu'ils
n'aillent pas dans la cuisine parce
qu'ils avaient un bordel c'est vrai
qu'aux secousses et le bordel entre les
merguez le poulet l'agneau vous qui avez
fait ça n'ont pas moi moi je moi je suis
rien qu'il est déjà trop d'institutions
j'aime est un gros
mais j'ai tout fait un nom et donc il
est évident avant un moment il ya eu un
coup de fil important et il est allé
dans la cuisine là où il fallait pas
aller où il y avait la serbie c'était
dégueulasse parterre donc on était quand
même extrêmement gêné mais bon les
tellement sympathique nicolas sarkozy
qui s'en serait totalement et ça s'est
bien passé que vous il avait quelqu'un
de vivant non c'est moi qui suis allé
chez eux ou au restaurant mais chez
jamais chez citi ben moi j'ai dîné à
plusieurs reprises mais toi aussi un au
restaurant mais c'est le mec de long
avec
à douchy voilà l'un d'eux louche il a sa
chance et la fdj à douchy et à lui ces
cas là aussi c'est la propriété dans le
coma je crois que vous étiez de moushin
et prison s'ils touchent y croit et
marion c'est douchy avec l'un de ses
deux fils ou non est d'accord et nous
pourrit la déco jean verney des
footballeurs george weah un grand
honneur devenu président du liberia rien
de bien se faire chier
moi j'ai tourné avec françois hollande
pendant plusieurs mois j'ai fait un
documentaire sur lui et vous comprenez
les questions non mais vous soyez
français non parce que c'est pas eu
vraiment de stars chez moi il ya kim
blue qui est venu chez moi pour un
tournage au wec fort ahoua don mello et
alors vous aviez peur qu'elle aille dans
la cuisine le fil important nicolas
pernikoff il était patron et 56 secondes
pour télévision du hamas est rattachée
moi j'allais plutôt chez les autres
enjeux mais jamais chez oui c'est ça le
foot moins cher chez jean louis borloo
chez les différentes personnes
c'est jean louis borloo était ministre
chez douste-blazy jean louis borloo s'il
est sympa jean louis borloo s'est vu à
jouer au tennis et laval s'est ou non
avec des prisons de boîtes hi fi
bourguignon quitté prison le club med
avec ge mike du bungee me des 5% la paix
à l'est fait déjeuner françois hollande
imec françois hollande est assez agglo
ah ouais ouais et alain bashung à
l'époque françois avec trois quarts
d'heure de retard parce que j'arrive à
me garer parce que personne ne le
prenais trop au sérieux à l'époque et
puis et puis il ya il a grimpé enfin
bien et vous je vous le dire n'était pas
comme nous fait une petite dépression
[Rires]
à beaucoup d'un seul et tu vois idée qui
dit un truc même sympathique il était à
5%
non mais c'est vrai nom de grandes stars
labrunie chez elle six mois oui mais
c'était parce que j'écrivais un livre
sur une chaleur et car l'ajustement
objets créatifs sur ouï oui je peux
aller chez lui voilà donc sérieux car là
pour carla bruni effectivement lui alors
lui seul sympathie lui ça lui a fait un
truc de fou j'ai joué j'ai dîné avec
bois avec beaucoup de gens célèbres mais
un chef de chez nous et bien sûr un chef
d'état j'ai dîné avec shimon peres ah
ouais ah oui aller et qui l'autre moi je
sais pas alain delon michel piccoli oui
non pas d'une telle annonce est dans sa
famille si matraques mais moi j'ai souri
les gens avec qui j'ai ma mais aussi
vous oublier